[Music]
we're people here from my people my
father Manganiello or Manganiello is
from a town called
Avellino which is outside of Naples and
then my mother is from her family from
the croatian coastline their Dalmatian
in the ocean Dalmatian so i am part you
know croatian Dalmatian and german
armenia german armenia's croatian
Dalmatian sicilian Babbo Natale no
italian you sounds like a grocery list
yes but you run out and grab me those
Dalmatians you speaking of what you just
said
where Schwarzenegger from Schwarzenegger
in Austria you work with him in the
movie oh yeah what was that like he's
the greatest music oh my god
he's the best can you can you do an
Arnold I can't just it's not like a
parody that's like real like one of the
first times we were out you know I I
went out to his table and was like hey
arnold you know it's joe from from the
movie he's like look at you you're all
pumped up and biceps and you'd be down
to the trap see you know in like and
you're just like oh my god i just want
to get off the phone and call my parents
no one told me you do what every person
working out is like one day Arnold will
be like doing great yeah you know we
went out to eat one time and the
waitress waitress just protein and the
waitresses would come up and it's one
poor girl looks like you know we have
specials today there's onion rings and
seven layer nachos he's like stop he's
like you punch amigos look at this
physique look at them look at the lats
he one of the whole thing again and he
was like he's so good to get the protein
forget the but I know you
the matches with the good protein you
know and she was just like you know
she's like sir this is Buffalo Wild
Wings kale
[Music]